what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alva
I'm John Humphrey that's right we're not
at our set we are at a hotel just
minutes away from the San Diego
Convention Center for comic-con 2019 so
tomorrow Friday July 19th I am hosting a
panel for the Amazon exclusive series
dark web independently produced which
blows my mind because I watched the
whole thing this week it was great
it's a serialized anthology series so
you have this one storyline that is
following a mystery of someone who went
missing and every episode interweaves a
tale from the dark web a lot of great
actors in it there's some really good
writing some really great directing too
so happy that the show is good because
it makes me proud to be hosting this
panel so if you have to be right around
the neighborhood right now make sure to
come by the panel tomorrow it's 1:30
p.m. at the Hornet Grand Theater same
day the show premieres any of the second
we hit the road of this Top Gun maverick
trailer dropped and that we were stuck
in traffic for about four and a half
hours mmm and now we're all cozied up
here and we're like alright let's watch
this they'll go pick up our Comic Con
that's right afterwards and then we'll
watch cab probably not it's probably
[Music]
thirty plus years of surface combat
medals citations only man shoot down
through the enemy plays in the last 40
years
you can't get a promotion won't retire
despite your best efforts you refuse to
die that's like Tom Cruise
you should be at least a two-star
admiral by now yet here you are captain
what is that
it's one of life's mysteries sir yeah
[Music]
Wow
friggin chompers man nostalgia
Jon Hamm
[Music]
every Connelly
of lady pilot
wow that is a crazy shot whoa Wow
the end is inevitable maverick the kind
of said it's work stinks
maybe so sir but not today
masking mean I'm Axworthy fell right
there who's doing the Joseph Kosinski
right yeah I liked his work on oblivion
with crews and we're looking at the work
here gosh Tom Cruise has a death wish
doesn't he he does once I feel like he
really does and he's just trying new
things until one of them finally takes
him down that is like not Tom Cruise's
death will be on screen at some point
like when you learned that shower isn't
the plane and it's just right on him the
entire time you know that's in camera
it's like you don't even question it
anymore like it's Tom Cruise you know
he's really doing that I have no idea of
the production behind this one like I
that's was one thing it's really cool
about is you know the fact that it's so
many so many years later since the first
Top Gun this is something that could
have easily copped out by easily doing
something that's a lot of CGI heavy but
they really highlighted that their
sequences are gonna be all in-camera
it's gonna be a lot of real piloting a
lot of real stunt work yeah and I didn't
see Joseph Kaczynski's last movie that
the firefighter movie or whatever but it
is interesting to me to see him work in
a realm that is very earth you know it's
all technology that were familiar with
and stuff and I thought that just
looking at the visuals it's like I have
a great concept for what the story is
gonna be but he really brings this
striking very symmetrical visual style
and you're watching like those planes
raised up on that platform through that
oval shaped yeah opening and stuff like
the imagery looks beautiful and you
really feel at least by this trailer the
power of these Jets and the just like
harrowing undertaking it must be to fly
them oh yeah it feels really intense I
was kind of taken aback by it to be
honest because you know it's like you
think it's hot gun yeah I was like we're
gonna turn it to like Ethan hood yeah
and we were right down the street from
the sleazy bar from the original movie
and yeah there's like none of that
flavor here which intrigues me because I
am a fan of when franchises come back
and letting themselves age instead of
just trying to copy what's from before
and like Tom Cruise but there is those
a lot of nostalgia show you there's a
whole montage remembers how good one and
I'm gonna look there's a few rules out
of that yeah maybe like goose came back
and died again or God or val kilmer will
make a little cameo I think he's gonna
come back at the very end to set up part
3 oh yeah it's gonna be like when crease
comes back that's when they CGI yeah go
I'm getting in that thing what are you
crazy yeah Tom Cruise is the only
practical flight and then everybody else
is on a green screen and i weirdly even
though it's a really short teaser just
because of the fact of the tone that
they were pitching us on you know really
dealing like what you talked about with
age I can already feel a lot of
Christopher McCord is writing being
infused in here like that's become Tom
Cruise's main guy yeah and then last but
right there Joseph Kosinski is like his
backup director yeah clearly likes
working with this guy to usually and and
I guess one thing I'm very curious about
is like Top Gun isn't the most Tony
Scott movie to ever exist but you know
with the loss of Tony Scott I'm curious
about how this movie is going to mesh
into the tone of the original one and
what its gonna take from his style I
don't feel like they're gonna be meshing
that tone at all Limor on it I think it
just wouldn't work it would feel really
cheesy it seems like they're going for
something that's evidently a lot bigger
because as we were getting refreshed so
what happened it's off gun one it's
primarily a lot of training in them yeah
like they call him he's a captain here
is it he's been part of this field for
so many years now and yet he hasn't
progressed past a certain point which is
interesting because I'm Cruz is an
overachiever and is talking about how
his time is come basically you know it's
been wondering how it's going to deal
with that because especially with like
planes and stuff a they usually I feel
like nowadays there's a lot more drone
technology going around so I'm what if
they're gonna explore that as well
yeah the modern place of Air Force
fighter pilots and stuff like that or I
think they were named and you know they
also got a bunch of new I mean Tom
Cruise seems to be the only returning
one but you got at Harrison here you see
Jon Hamm I didn't know any of these
people are gonna be in it Jennifer
Connelly at one point there's a lot of
big players here I hope they're actually
utilized you know I do too I mean there
there has to be an ensemble of some kind
here I can't
can't imagine this is gonna be Tom
Cruise and Ed Harris like grimly talking
to each other although how fascinating
would that be if like most of this film
is silent and it's just aerial
photography I mean a little vibe that I
picked up on was how much more serious
maverick has become yeah and then when
you get back to those nostalgic moments
you know the cool with enough the the
tarp from the bike and riding the bike
you see you see the Tom Cruise charisma
yeah I think of Top Gun I think of Tom
Cruise smiling laughing he's so heavy
and so serious in this trailer so I feel
like there's gonna be this plot light of
him going back to like what was it like
when I first became a pilot you know
what was that feeling I need to go back
to that I'm finally again I could see a
lot of that energy in here being a few
smart they're gonna explain away Charlie
and I wonder if all these years later
there's some random line of expertise or
maybe they sent him up with like a
really young hotshot pilot who he finds
romance with you know like a 50 year old
Tom Cruise and a three year old pilot
seems like he's always got a younger
romantic interest to think if we weren't
pressured into covering the in chapter 2
trailer we might have made it to the
panel this morning or a paramount then
we could have been they're not covering
this oh yeah all right guys well are you
excited for Top Gun maverick do you
think you'll be better than the mission
impossible franchise do you wish the
dark universe was still ongoing I do I
do to me I could really use that touch
well guys
subscribe to the reel rejects anything
that comes out at Comic Con nine times
out of ten we're gonna be pretty late to
it just a heads up we're gonna be really
late and if you're at the Horton Grant
theater tomorrow would love do for you
just come say hi or try to catch us
around the convention center or
something like that or catch one of the
dark web screenings the ID or Saturday
night Friday or Saturday night and make
sure to catch dark web online Amazon
exclusive seriously it's a great show I
had a wonderful time a lot of emotion
throughout go check it out as soon as
you can see